The fastest way to lose an argument is
to start one.
Can I get a witness? Man, [music] I tell
you there's been so many times I have
gotten into an argument and realized I
did this all to myself. [music] Anybody
relate to that? Welcome to the Jefferson
Fisher podcast. I'm throwing it back in
the truck
where it all began. Here we go. [music]
So,
what I want to share with you today is
something that's been on my heart and
that is how to reduce the relational
arguments in your life. Now, hear me. I
need you to hear me. This is a
disclaimer
in bright letters, all caps.
I am no marriage guru, all right? I am
married. What I'm about to share with
you has come at great cost because I
have done things that have
been terrible, all right? I have gotten
us into bad positions, bad arguments,
bad conflicts and a lot of the things
I'm going to teach you are the ways that
I have gotten through it. And the way
that we, C and I, work through things.
This is a process. This is growth. So,
how can I give you some insight here?
Number one,
when you start a conflict
anytime with a spouse, a friend, a
co-worker
I want you to question for a second, how
does the argument start?
When somebody is complaining to you,
when they are saying the thing they
don't like, "I don't like how you leave
this out or put this here or the way you
wrote that document or sent that email
or worded this or did this." Okay.
Whenever they send you something that's
not the argument. That's not somebody
starting an argument. The argument
starts when you say
"That's not true. That's not what I
said. But yeah, but what about But what
about But yeah, but
like
all of those things, that's
that's where the argument begins, right
there. Not when they first have their
sign, their signal, they they put out
that signal of communication. It is when
you
respond and get what? Defensive with
that. It is when instead of receiving
what is being sent,
you immediately put up your spam
blocker, right? You just go
nope, as if you have a red button that
you goes
I am not dealing with this. I do not
accept what you're putting out. Now, I'm
not talking about
if someone is being verbally abusive or
gaslighting or anything like that. Put
Put that aside. This is just your
everyday conflict most of the time that
you deal with and how to get better at
it. So, I want you to have the mindset
of arguments do not start
from what the other person has said.
Arguments start when you butt up against
it, when you get defensive, you pick up
that shield and you just go, "That's not
what I said. That's not what I did.
That's not what Yeah, but what about
As soon as you go into that mode
of "That's not true. You know, what I
did
you you are That's the argument and
that's how you lose.
That's how you lose. I want you to have
this mindset, okay? This mindset
that when you hear somebody, they are
not fighting you, they are fighting to
be understood by you.
They are fighting to be understood by
you. And when you
find that it's you have this knee-jerk
reaction, which is going to happen. Like
it's not it's not a if
things are going to go south, it's when
they're going to go south. It's going to
happen. Listen to me. It's going to
happen. Whenever that Whenever it does,
I need you to find a path to
reduce
the length of
that pain. So, when I find that I'm
getting defensive because I'm going to
sometimes have that knee-jerk reaction
and go,
"That's not true. That's not That's not
accurate. That's not what I said."
That is creating more pain in the
conversation because I'm skipping over
what I'm going to talk to you in section
two is I'm skipping over the
need by her or by a friend or by anybody
to feel heard and understood in that
moment. I'm totally skipping right over
it and going to what I'm fighting for.
And the quicker I can get to that
mindset of they're not fighting me,
they're fighting to be understood by
this. The faster I can get there.
Even when I mess up, the faster I can
get there, the better it's going to be.
So, the mindset of they're not fighting
you, they're fighting to be understood.
How do we do that? Number two, we
affirm.
We affirm. Let me tell you what I've
learned.
There are phrases that I'm going to
share with you on how to affirm the
moment. How do you make them feel heard
and understood and calm everything down?
Because what they're hearing, their
whole nervous system is is going, "Hey,
you're safe here. You're not threatened.
You don't have to
uh continue to give all the evidence,
all the reasoning, all the justification
uh and overtalk, overexplain, and to go,
"Oh my gosh, this person gets it. They
They They They get it. They They They
understand."
Like I want you to
to
receive this concept for a second.
If somebody says something to you and
you go, "I get it. I really do. I get
it."
Does it make you feel
like they really get it or they're just
trying to like
placate you? They're They're just trying
to push it on. They go, "Ah, I get it."
Verbalizing I get it doesn't do it.
They will feel I get it when you use
words that actually affirm what they
just said. So, often I'll have people
who go, "Jefferson, you know, my spouse
said something to me
and I just I didn't know what to say.
So, I just kind of go quiet and I'll go,
you know exactly what to say.
Because they just told you.
All you need to do is repeat either back
to them or tell them that that's okay to
feel.
Most of the time in relational
arguments, I'm talking people you are
married to in a relationship with
work relationships in any kind, okay?
That romantic non-romantic that
they are in many ways just wanting to
feel as though you get it.
And how we do that is by telling them
it's okay to feel that way. So many
arguments in my life have been created
because I skipped over that fact.
I chose instead to tell somebody how to
feel. To go, what do you what do you
mean you're concerned about that? And I
start arguing with them about why they
shouldn't be concerned about that. Why
they shouldn't be afraid of that. Why I
think that's a stupid idea for them to
be worried about that. And how you know,
I think it's dumb that this is a And
listen, this has crushed me, all right?
Because I'm missing it. I'm missing the
plot
when that happens. When I go into
telling them how they should feel.
That never works.
Well, when you tell somebody, calm you
need to calm down.
Does that ever work? No.
It only confirms with them that what
they're feeling isn't okay, isn't safe.
And what does that do to their nervous
system? It just erupts it.
Erupts it. You'll just have a volcano of
emotion because you had the chance to
put out that fire and instead you poured
gasoline on it. And in the in the
process you you
you created more of a rupture. You
created more distrust. Before we get
going, I want to take a moment to tell
you about Timeline. Now, when we talk
about aging well, we usually [music]
think of things like diet, exercise,
sleep. Well, those are all well and
good, but what I want us to do is also
have to keep looking down at the
cellular level. That's right. You know
it, the mitochondria. If you remember
from school, mitochondria, the
powerhouse of the cell. Well, it's
actually a real thing. And in fact, if
you might be aging, go I feel like I
don't have as much energy. Yeah, that's
that's because mitochondria can actually
get old and damaged. And that's why I've
been taking Mitopure from Timeline. It's
a small little like tapioca gummy that
tastes excellent, actually. You can say
you can take up to four. I always take
four. That's how good they taste. And
what they do, it's one of this
clinically uh proven research that
they've been putting into to help clean
out old mitochondria to renew the energy
that you have. So, Timeline has spent
over 15 years researching mitochondrial
health. And in human clinical studies,
people saw improvements in muscle
strength and energy without changing
their routine, which is awesome. For me,
this is about staying strong, staying
sharp, and feeling like myself as I
continue to get older.
Timeline's clinically proven formula is
now available at a new lower price.
Mitopure now starts at $79 when you go
to timeline.com/jefferson.
Go to timeline.com/jefferson
to learn more. Now, let's keep going.
So, when I say they've already told you
what to say, here's what I mean by that.
If somebody in your life is making a
statement about hey,
um
you know, I I really
feel frustrated when you do X, Y, and Z.
Or maybe they don't even give it a name.
They don't even say frustration. They
say, "I really don't like
uh that you come home
late. You're always home late. And you
never seem to be on time."
Rather than you fighting these going to
the accuracy of the statement, right?
That's what we want to do first. We want
to go hold up. When was the last time
that I've done that? And they go, "I
wasn't late last night." And they go,
"Yeah, but you were late the night
before." And they go, "Well, that's
Well, that's Okay, well, the week
before." And you it becomes what? An
accuracy contest. Who has the better
memory? Why Why are you doing that?
Because you're wanting to discount what
they're saying. You're going to the
facts and the accuracy of what's there.
You're missing it. That's not the issue.
It's not about the milk. Okay? It is
about the feeling underneath.
And instead of trying to go, "That's not
true. No, I'm not I'm not that late.
What are you talking about? I'm I'm here
all the time." Rather than that,
it is pausing
and go,
"I can see how that would be really
frustrating."
"I can see how
that would make you feel like I don't
want to be here."
"Yeah, that makes total sense to me."
Or, "I hear that."
"That makes sense."
"Of course you feel that way. I I
I I I I can hear all of that."
You see how
when I say those statements,
the other person
is going to drop their shoulders and get
it because the issue is not that
you were late. Okay? The issue is it
makes them feel something. What is that
feeling? Is that you're not with them?
You don't want to be around them? You're
avoiding them? And it's going to feed
into this all the fear and insecurity of
everything else. Now,
my my issue is not that I'm late. I've
done tons of other things, believe me,
that I have had to
start scratching the surface and I
realized, man, I'm just fighting about
the milk. I'm just fighting up here and
I'm missing it. Jefferson, you're
missing it. And what is the key to doing
that? Is to simply affirm. So, three, I
want to give you some affirmation
statements, some affirming phrases that
are going to help you like they felt me.
I've already mentioned a few.
And these are ones that
I want you to imagine and you can come
up with any of your own, but what you're
doing is
the goal is to tell the other person
that what they are feeling
is okay.
All right, what they're thinking
That it's all right for them. That their
emotions are not too much.
And you can handle it.
And you're a safe place. You're a person
who can absorb and take and sit with
these emotions rather than discounting
them and telling them how stupid they
are and how they should feel something
else that makes you more comfortable
with it. Hey, I'm preaching to the choir
here, too. All right?
So, what are some affirming phrases?
These are phrases that I typically begin
with what you hear.
Right?
Or I see. Same with the the the senses,
what we talk about in disagree. Instead
of I disagree, I see things differently.
So, it could be as simple as I hear
that.
I hear you.
Easy as that. It's not I understand.
Is it Hear me out. Distinction.
Not I understand. Because when you say
that, you're going everything you feel
is everything I feel. I I get it. And
they go, "No, you don't. You don't
understand." Right? That that's it's
it's Don't ever try to equate
what you have felt in your life with
somebody is feeling right now. I know it
might be extremely well-intentioned, but
it's not going to land nearly as well.
Okay? It is best not to say I understand
unless it is some type of directive or
some type of plan that you're putting in
place and you're going, "Are Are we all
on the same page here?" Right now, we're
affirming. And that means I hear you. I
hear that.
That makes sense.
I I can see why you'd feel that way. I
can see how you feel that way.
Like you hear how I am
I It's like I'm check marking their
state of mind. I'm check marking their
feeling in that moment.
Here's the And there's lots of phrases
and I I've I feel like I've given you
enough to understand here.
Here's what I need you to
cue in on. So, just focus in with me for
a second. You're going to get it wrong.
It's going to happen.
Go to back to that phrase.
Whatever affirming phrase makes sense to
you.
Here's what I'm going to double down on.
There's going to be times you don't feel
like it. Ooh.
There's going to be some times, y'all,
you don't feel like it.
You just You're angry.
You're
frustrated. You're mad about what they
did. And how dare they mess up my day?
And you know, it's just like they're
going to bring this up. They're always
bringing this up. That's going to
happen. You're going to get into these
these mindsets, these modes, that are
going to
um, you know,
can be destructive.
When that happens, and it will, because
what it's saying is now you're getting
flooded. Right? You're
Now, you're getting in a bad place, and
it's going to erupt on your side. When
that happens, I need you to go to what I
call the minimal
viable response.
Right? That's uh that's a play on words
from in
um, in tech, they [snorts] say minimal
viable product. Like, let just get the
prototype out. Just You can't be
perfect. Don't try to be fancy. You
We're not looking for the best, the
perfect. We're just looking for
something. Something.
Because something is better than
nothing, right? So,
I when I feel like I'm getting flooded
in the argument,
I My go-to phrase is, "I hear you."
That's it. That's just my go-to phrase.
You need to have have go-to phrase that
you affirm in the argument.
In fact, if you use that phrase, most
likely you will not have an argument
because you are you are affirming what
they're saying. Before I get going, I
want to take a moment to tell you about
Monarch. Well, I don't know about you,
but tax season is now behind us
>> [music]
>> and now is one of those times where you
get to stop and look at everything and
go
where did it all go?
That's when I catch myself and I go, how
can we help with this? Monarch money is
that solution because I don't know about
you, but I don't want to just look back.
I also want to make progress and that's
why I love Monarch. It shows me where my
money's going all in one single place.
Simplify your finances with Monarch.
Monarch is the all-in-one personal
finance tool designed to make your life
easier. What it does is it brings your
entire financial life. So, think
budgeting, accounts, investments, net
worth, future planning together in one
dashboard all on your phone or on your
laptop. Feel aware and in control of
your finances this tax season and get
50% off your Monarch subscription with
the code Jefferson. See everything all
at once, all at the dashboard and give
yourself the peace that you need.
Achieve your financial goals for good
with Monarch, the all-in-one tool that
makes money management simple. Use code
Jefferson at monarch.com for half off
your first year. That's 50% off at
monarch.com code Jefferson. Now, let's
keep going.
Right now, I know that you're going,
well, Jefferson,
but they're wrong. You mean I just have
to agree with them? You mean I have to
just go with it and lay down and let
them walk over me? No, that's not what
I'm saying.
What I'm saying is there is a time
to raise your point.
And it's not as soon as they have raised
their flag and their complaint. It's not
when you get to shut it right down and
tell them how wrong they are.
That's That's not what I said. That's
not right. Yeah, but that's that's not
at all.
Yeah, but what about
No, we're not going to point the finger
right at them again. Instead, we're
going to affirm
and we're going to say,
"You know what? If
if that's how it came across to you,
that that makes sense why you'd feel
that way."
Oof. Awesome affirming statement.
And they're going to go, "Thank you."
Right? Maybe they're going to keep
talking. You affirm again.
They might talk a little bit more. You
affirm again. You are telling their
system, "We're good here.
This is a safe place." And then
you're going to know when it's time.
But you're going to ask something. We're
going to connect the bridge. This is a
bridge now to what you want to share.
And we're going to ask. We're going to
say,
"Can I share
where I was coming from?
Can I share my intention when I did
that?
Are you open to me
telling you what I how I experienced
that?
Can you hear the difference
of me going,
"What are you What are you talking
about? That's that's not at all what
happened." versus affirming and saying,
"Whenever you're ready,
I'd like to share my thinking of what
what's happening, my perspective. Can I
share with you my perspective of what I
see, of what I did, or what my intention
was, or the thought behind that?"
And they're going to go, "Yes."
And then you get to share your
perspective.
And hopefully the other person's going
to affirm you. If they don't,
understand it has been
argument avoided. Mischief managed.
All right? When you're able to share
your perspective in a way that talks
from, "I see you where you are coming
from. Got that."
Instead of telling you your point is
wrong, I'm going to ask if I can share
my perspective, rather than just
flopping it onto you and saying, "Eat
this."
I'm going to tell you
or ask
I'd like to
I'd like to share where I was coming
from when I said that. I like to share
my perspective or give my perspective or
give you another take.
Can I give you another way of thinking
about that?
That is such a better way. I I have in
my own life diffused many would-be
arguments
by affirming
bridging
and sharing my perspective.
But I have to affirm first. And if I
mess up and I will mess up
I find that the quicker I can get to
affirming and stopping myself from just
putting my flag in the ground, drawing
the line in the sand and I can get
faster at putting down my sword and my
shield
the shorter those little blips and those
arguments, they're really the big
moments just become speed bumps, right?
Where you're you're able to feel it,
understand it, get it and then
resolve it. And that's that's what we're
going for. So,
let me give you some different
perspectives. We talk about marriage
from my own life, my own world. So,
that's every day
anything, especially if you have kids,
don't have kids or you're boyfriend,
girlfriend, whatever it is.
Um
and you are
dealing with difference of opinion,
affirm.
Bridge to your perspective. If you're at
work
okay, and somebody has a different idea
about something, rather than telling
them their idea is dumb
and how you
think that it's, you know, they
shouldn't all be worried about that
looming whatever coming up
affirm
that you know what? I I can see why that
would concern you. I can see I can hear
that that that's a really frustrating
moment. It sounds like something that's
really been bothering you for a while.
Affirm that statement, then bridge. Can
I give you a different way of looking
about that? Can I share with you how I
see that?
It just is going to pull everything
down. Everybody's shoulders start to
drop, voices start to lower, and you
know what? What could have been an
argument just turns into a conversation.
And that's
what we're looking for.
A nice, wonderful
conversation.
I hope you don't mind if I share that
with you today. This was something that
was on my heart. And I thought, you know
what? I'm going to
just say what's up to y'all in the
truck. Wherever you're watching,
wherever you're listening, if you would,
if you find that this content is
valuable to you, I'm going to ask that
wherever you're listening, you please
subscribe, press the button that says
subscribe. It doesn't cost anything. Or
like, or heart, or comment. Any of that
stuff helps. It's all good. You see the
car seats in the back now? I can't you
My son has another one, but they're
getting big, y'all.
People There's some who are watching
this podcast who know that I started
with them in car seats.
And now we're in booster seats.
Um it's circle of life, y'all. We're
we're we're getting older. This is a
podcast that's going to be sponsored by
Cozy Earth. I have to tell you, y'all,
there is a product that we got from Cozy
Earth. Just hear me out.
It's a blanket, all right? And it's
called the cuddle blanket. And
I was very skeptical about this name.
And I was like, who wants to cuddle, you
know, under a cuddle blanket?
It's not about cuddling with somebody
else. It's about cuddling with the
blanket itself. It is the softest,
it has like weight to it.
We fight over it in our house, and it's
huge, but we still
Right now, it's the talk of our evenings
of who who gets to use the blanket. So,
that's that's for you. I promise, it's
worth trying. Don't don't hate on a
blanket. Don't knock it till you try it.
Believe me. Didn't think I'd ever be
talking about a blanket on here, but
here it is. All right,
cozyearth.com/jefferson use the code
Jefferson for up to 20% off.
Jefferson for up to 20% off. Affirming
have a mindset.
Have the mindset they are not fighting
you, they're fighting to be heard by
you. We're going to use affirming
phrases. We're going to have our go-to
phrases, and we're going to bridge to
our own perspective. And that is going
to reduce the relational arguments in
your life. If you want to lose an
argument, the fastest way to do it is to
start one. Be good.